[Music]
your performance in the movie is so
gut-wrenching and so powerful when I'm
wondering how your friends have reacted
to it it was it's I'm just curious
you've you've had friends of yours go
and see the movie and they have to see
you go through this incredible
experience I know it's your character
but still it's it's you yeah and I know
they've been so supportive and I've
gotten lots of emails just and phone
calls of their support but one of my
classmates he decided he was gonna go
see the movie with his with a girl he
was interested in he'd been on one date
with this girl and he was a cab we could
go see 12 years of slave was there a
second date and I was like I don't know
whether that's a good idea
it's not a date movie no no especially
if you're a crier like he is he he cries
a lot
and I was like I don't think it's a good
idea but he was like no it'll be okay
you know she'll see my soft side he went
for the date and he sends me a text and
says you know I was crying so hard that
my armpits were wet with tears so how is
this is his relationship with this woman
working out it was the left he blew it
oh you're from Kenya yes that right and
and you've lived in then you lived in
did you live in Massachusetts I did I'm
from Massachusetts I can't imagine what
it's like to go from from Kenya and then
to Massachusetts must have been huge
culture shock oh yes and the worst thing
was the cold you know I grew in Kenya we
don't have four seasons we just have
rain and no rain you know right and cold
but nalle' for Nia we just have no rain
it's her one season yeah so that's all
you have is you have rain or no rain
just know that's it and like you know
the rain comes with colder weather but
like we this idea of like dressing for
seasons is very foreign so I remember
watching a show like sisters and I was
so excited about going to the u.s. where
you get to wear a coat and you walk into
a room and you can hang your coat cuz we
don't do that right and so when I got to
Massachusetts my body just didn't know
what cold felt like I
so I remember by before Halloween I was
already in gloves and a ski mask you
couldn't tell what race bike was
completely bundled up walking around
yeah and it's like 62 degrees and my
friends were like you might want to lose
some layers because it's gonna get
colder well you'd become you know it's
funny you bring up close because you're
so you're getting so much attention for
the great choices that you make with
your clothing and your sense of style
you're on the cover of I think it's a
People magazine and I keep it right here
at all time but you know you wear these
gorgeous I think we have you wearing a
look at this so this outfit
like that it feels like you're just kind
of fearless I mean to wear a cape just
seems like so such a cool thing to do
but I would I mean I'd love to wear a
cape and fight crime
you should try I've tried every one
laughs it's caught in revolving doors
did you did you like wearing a cape I
thoroughly enjoyed it I felt like I
could fly at any moment and I had our
Kelly's I believe I can fly in my head
all night and I would use it a lot for
flourishes I did I would say things like
I must be going do that a lot
yeah well I would do that you know
always be like let's go yeah you know I
should all wear capes there should be
Kate day
[Applause]